lupita you play a former space pirate
who now runs a bar I'm wondering this
seems sort of to me like a female Sam
Malone from the American TV show Cheers
this may not you might not know this I'm
just gonna say could you talk about your
relationship with Yoda and is it is it
convivial tell her a little bit about
the structures actual I said yeah that's
a good movie two ideas for Disney yeah
with Yoda which is something I like to
Kenshi well I will say this in an
attempt to save my friend Lupita okay
from this slightly odd awesomely geeky
question which is that I do believe that
Maz and Yoda at one point had crossed
paths but that is not something of
course due to the events of past films
happens in this one okay okay I recently
were in a play on in New York City and
I'm wondering what the experience was
acting with other actors versus what I
can only imagine in this was at some
times a very solitary experience
shooting this movie and yeah fortunately
for me JJ had me be a part of principal
photography so my very first experience
of motion capture was on the actual sets
with the actual actors so I I am
eternally grateful to him for giving me
that because it was a great way to get
into this wonderful crazy thing called
motion capture I got to be on those sets
and see those things and feel them the
art direction in this there's so much
detail even when you're standing on that
set that is it's mesmerizing
I think audiences are going to be there
they're there they're gonna have a very
immersive experience much like we had
filming it and so it was good to have
that and the physicality is something
that then carries on into theater for
sure and that was the thing that
attracted me to the idea of playing
motion capture the the idea of working
on a character that wasn't limited by my
friends my physical circumstances and I
could I could work with my body in new
ways and I've continued that on to the
stage if I can say one thing that Lupita
would not which is that she was
remarkably tireless and and willing to
experiment with different versions of
this character and it was kind of an
amazing thing to discover over various
iterations of Maz what she sounded like
how she moved it was really I've never
been through this before with an actor
where we got to discover again and again
and again kind of how to better tell the
story we were telling and it was just I
I always felt guilty every time we
started up another session another we
did some reshoots works and every single
time Lupita was willing and game and and
deeply committed and into finding maz
kanata's voice and I again I'm just
eternally grateful
you